volkswagen introduced the Passat 42
years ago since then the car maker has
sold more than 22 million of the sedan
and station wagon versions were a wide
now the eighth generation Passats are
hitting the streets
I impossible Chester Matas Kurt says he
drove the new passat variant a few weeks
ago but this time he's going to look at
the sedan version he saw me later on by
the passat station wagon is especially
popular in Germany buyers abroad prized
the sedan it makes for comfortable
driving over long distances and not just
because of its cushy seats
let's talk about Mata says the ride is
very comfy but not so soft that the car
feels like it blacks grip he says this
is a result of the extended wheelbase
and its external dimensions such as
wheelbase and vehicle length there's
little difference between the notchback
sedan and the station wagon LED rear
lights come as standard and all the
different trim packages montes really
likes the new infotainment system which
has a large screen and functions almost
like a smartphone you can zoom in using
two fingers and type in where you want
to go that's nice sure the new Passat
said terior manages to look both classic
and modern at the same time one of the
highlights is the active info display
which replaces the dashboard instruments
with a TFT screen the entirely digital
sat-nav can also be displayed right in
front of the driver
pw is also offering an entirely new
range of engines for the Passat our test
model is equipped with a 2.0 TDI which
puts out 110 kilowatts of power it comes
with a dual clutch transmission and
bluemotion technology VW says the car
can go from zero to 100 kilometers an
hour in 8.9 seconds and consumes just
4.5 liters of fuel per 100 kilometers
death pilot well the 2-liter TDI
bluemotion isn't the top-of-the-line
engine montes finds is perfectly
adequate and regular traffic and when he
occasionally needs to overtake other
vehicles quickly the Passat can also be
equipped with a myriad of assist systems
such as front assist plus City emergency
braking with pedestrian detection and
the Park Assist system can also actually
park the vehicle forwards and
perpendicular spaces
so my fat as a for montes explains that
once the system has found an available
parking space you select what you want
to do he wants to park forwards and
right away the vehicle takes over the
steering he only has to change gears and
step on the gas and brakes gang of xn
attends and one gaussian are so Martha
says it looks like he really will get
into this space he says he's not doing
anything just watching putting his foot
on the gas and breaking he looks around
and says the park assist is going about
its work very precisely but he figures
he could have got the job done quicker
on his own mosey saga does he own a
decent haces Tenten sunshine leash
schneller curve isn't Vera when movie
heads from aza would anger Patinkin now
that we're parked Montes takes the
opportunity to show us the rear seat is
missing even though the new Passat is
slightly shorter than his predecessor he
says backseat passengers enjoy plenty of
leg room with the sedan he says you
could even pull down the seat bench and
climb right into the trunk no it's not
too comfy back here but wait mata still
has to give us his verdict so it's back
in the driver's seat
our tester says that just like the
passat variant the sedan is no bargain
but for the money you get very good
workmanship with very good materials and
lots of modern technology and that has
its price that's not the evens I implies
that price starts at just under twenty
six thousand euros in Germany the passat
sedan and passat variant will also be
available with a hybrid engine letting
the car travel up to 50 kilometers in
all-electric mode
you